for these titles in bookstores this
coming week and watch for the authors in
the near future on book tv and on
booktv.org
the name of the book is the malaria
project the author is karen masterson
ms masterson
what is malaria
malaria is a series of disease really
it's a it's not one disease it's many
diseases caused by several parasites all
from the genus plasmodium and these
different parasites do different things
and you find them in different parts of
the world
but they
all
cause
some similar symptoms like
intense fevers like furnace hot fevers
and bone deep chills and
body pains and headaches
some varieties will hide in your liver
and relapse years later you never know
whether you've gotten rid of it some
varieties like the kind you find in
africa can clump together and cause
circulatory problems and put you in a
coma so you can be playing soccer in the
morning and by the evening you're dead
so their their malaria is the
the word that we use to describe
the diseases that are caused by this
genus of plasma as this genus of
parasites how many types are there would
you say yeah well there are four there
are four that cause human malaria
although there is a monkey malaria that
is jumping species
and it's called nose eye and it will
likely become the fifth human malaria
it's in the process of doing that now
this is the way these parasites have
survived the ages they infected
dinosaurs
and made it through the ice ages
probably in birds there are many
varieties of bird malaria
then they went on to infect other
species including primates
and the primate ver
species are what evolved to infect us
how many people a year infected with
malaria you know that number is a
squishy one because there's
uh it's very hard to measure because so
many of the infections go uncounted but
the world health organization estimates
around 300 to 500 000
a year
and
i'm sorry
300 to 500 million a year and about a
million die every year and most of those
are children in africa so why hasn't it
been eradicated
because uh
the parasites that cause the disease are
part of the environment they are carried
by mosquitoes so to get rid of all the
areas are carried out normal areas are
carried by mosquitoes so to
eradicate
malaria you need to either remove people
from
mosquito populations or kill all the
mosquitoes and
both have been
very difficult to do so we had we had
malaria throughout the united states
malaria was was prevalent throughout the
world
up until the 20th century and then when
scientists
figured out that it was the mosquito
that carried it but it wasn't carried in
bad air the word malaria
comes from the italian words male arya
and back before the turn of the century
scientists believe that it rose up from
swamps and that you breathed it in and
you
became sick because the fevers always
came about around
the
spring summer time when the waters were
warming and you could smell the swamps
once we figured out that it was caused
by mosquitoes which was in 1898
the
the focus was on killing mosquitoes so
in countries that could and in regions
that could afford the anti-mosquito work
and put screens on homes
where where people were better off and
had health care the malaria rates
plummeted and
elimination of malaria
occurred although there were still some
outbreaks but in like the u.s south in
italy in southern europe
the because mosquitoes live longer and
they're more of them it was much harder
to get rid of malaria and those areas
especially the u.s south tended to be
less economically developed than the
northern
they say northern europe or the northern
parts of the united states
karen masterson
where is malaria today
where can you find malaria you can find
malaria
just about
anywhere where people are poor
where people live in poverty
or where people are fighting wars
because
wars develop the perfect ecosystem for
mosquitoes
because you tear apart the landscape and
create swamps where mosquitoes breed and
then because the parasites that cause
mosquito can survive any climate
the one that hides in your liver
will wait until the mosquito season to
launch an infection in your blood so
that when mosquitoes come to bite you
they drink them in and the cycle
continues or in the tropics the deep
tropics
where you tend to find
most
most of the world's intense poverty
malaria is just endemic and it's always
there the mosquitoes live
with
plenty of
blood meals from the population and
the population ends up just living with
malaria year round so that's about 40
percent of the globe
40 of the human population live with
malaria
who discovered
that it was a mosquito that carried
malaria ronald ross and he won the nobel
prize for that
he
then went on to
create the first of what came to be
known as the mosquito brigades so his
whole focus for england he was a he was
a researcher
a british researcher his whole focus was
to try to reduce mosquito populations
in
the
colonies of great britain mostly africa
so that the colonists could penetrate
deeper into these countries for
resources because malaria was blocking
the way
he was not successful in places like
west africa
because the mosquito populations there
were so huge and the carrier of malaria
in
most areas of africa is called the
anopheles gambi and it is the
most efficient carrier of these
parasites it's also what entomologists
call a geriatric mosquito because it
lives so long and because
a mosquito must bite you twice
to transmit malaria they have to bite
you
to drink in the parasites
and then those parasites sexually
reproduce in the gut of the mosquito
and then
a week to two weeks later depending on
the temperature
the the the egg sac that's left behind
in the mosquito gut will burst with new
offspring those offspring will get into
the mosquito saliva and then the
mosquito has to bite you again
so
mosquitoes in the north don't really
live that long whereas in
places like africa they live a long time
and so
they can easily carry a leader malaria
survive between
those the the two weeks that they the
week to two weeks that they need to
carry
the eggs in their guts and then infect
people
is there an antidote to malaria
is there an antidote there are drugs
that can clear the parasites from your
blood yes um they
tend not to work for very long because
the parasites they don't clear all the
parasites and the parasites that survive
end up getting sucked in by mosquitoes
and they have developed then resistance
to the drugs and then the mosquitoes
spread those resistant parasites around
to populations so
drugs last a short while i was at a
conference yesterday where they talked
about
the spread of resistance to the most
recent
series of anti-malaria drugs called the
artemis artemisinins and um
these these resistant parasites are
spreading
from cambodia out to other parts of the
world and
we're seeing the resistant parasites
even in africa which is quite
frightening because this is the
frontline drug
for african countries and most of the
deaths
caused by malaria happen in africa
how effective are nets
sleeping nets especially
you know nets are
probably the best technology we have
against malaria
but
you need to convince people to use them
and it's hard to convince
people living in sweltering heat
to put another layer
of material between them and what little
air they get especially during the
summer when it's hot
another problem
is that this is something else that was
talked about at the conference yesterday
uh the mosquitoes they had they they
they do what um
uh entomologists call uh refractory
behavior they figure out
what's preventing them from getting
their blood meal and they change their
behavior so we're seeing in africa where
bed nets are being used quite intensely
where global health programs are there
really working with the villages to make
sure that bed nets are used at night
especially um where there are young
children involved and they are seeing
mosquitoes biting earlier in the day
before people go to bed
so
these you know this is it's a it's a
good technology
in the united states we put up screens
and screens protect you for longer than
a bed net will it protects you as soon
as you go into the house
and you're cooking dinner and you're
doing your nightly chores and
you're still protected from the mosquito
bite whereas in africa the bed net you
it's there for sleeping and sleeping
only and when these mosquitoes change
their behaviors they can still get
access to you another problem is that
most of the global health programs have
focused on children saving children's
lives and the lives of pregnant women
because pregnant women lose their
what's called a
acquired immunity over time
if you're infected enough you develop a
certain level of immunity to
the deadly
symptoms of malaria so that you will
survive it feels like a flu basically
you feel you feel horrible and
you still must lie in bed and you can't
go and harvest your crops if you need to
but you but you won't die because you
have this this certain level of immunity
against the disease pregnant women lose
that and the children don't have it yet
so most of the global health programs
have just focused on saving lives and
now they're talking about the need
really to get at the larger population
because the larger population
[Music]
of people carry the parasites that the
mosquitoes pick up and then give to
pregnant women and children so
they're not able to break the cycle of
infection just by focusing on chil
pregnant women and children so now this
is a much
larger
problem and a much
bigger effort that they have to make and
it will require a lot more money
if elimination you know there's some
people use the word eradication but
eradication when you're talking about a
disease that exists in the environment
is a tricky word
most of the people who work in the field
of malaria especially
cdc the people who work on the ground
and understand the disease we'll just
use this word elimination try to try to
reduce the the number of infected people
and the number of mosquitoes so that
you don't
reach the threshold of
an outbreak you need to have a certain
number of each
to reach the threshold of a break up an
outbreak um if you can get those numbers
down malaria will still exist in the
environment but it won't be endemic and
it won't become constantly infecting
people
can so malaria can be passed from person
to person
in any way oh just through mosquitoes
just through so if i have malaria and i
sneeze all over you you are not going to
get it
if i you know if i you know if i wipe
the sweat on my forehead and then shake
your hand you are not going to get it it
has to come to you from a mosquito and
it has to be a mosquito that has had the
parasites in there and it's got long
enough for
the egg sac to burst and send these what
i call them baby parasites i think i
think of them in in their in the life
cycle um
that's kind of the you know the infants
that are in the saliva that
the mosquito bites you within minutes
um you know anywhere from minutes to a
day those parasites
uh get to your liver to avoid your
immune system and then they stay
and they they reproduce and they feed on
your liver liver cells and then when
they're mature enough they bust out of
your liver and they attack your blood
cells and destroy your blood cells until
you become very sick and your body
responds with a high fever
the high fever is a sign that your
immune system has really kicked in and
has tried tried to
reduce the number of parasites so that
you no longer
sick enough for the symptoms but you
still have the parasites in your in your
in your blood and there they mature
again and they become sexually distinct
and they they swim to the surface
cells the surface blood cells and they
emit a chemical
to attract a mosquito so that the
mosquito when you have malaria you are
more attractive to mosquitoes they they
pick up on the chemical and they come
and they bite you and they they they
drink in these these what i call adult
versions of these powers they're
shape-shifters so they're they're
constantly shaping their uh changing
their shape and then they get into the
mosquito and there they fuse they
sexually fuse and they create a
genetically unique
set of offspring
that are stick shaped and they get into
the saliva and then the cycle continues
karen masterson how did you get
interested in this topic
so i was a political reporter
and
i had i had covered congress for quite a
while and i was interested in doing
something else i wanted to get back to
science writing because i had been an
environmental reporter for the
philadelphia inquirer i covered the
environment for they covered the pine
barrens which was great um
and
to do that i decided that i wanted to um
uh
research a scientist because you can
teach science through people right if
you're a narrative writer if you're a
storyteller and so i was up at the
national archives looking for the world
war ii records of linus pauling
and the two-time
nobel prize winner and i worked with
archivists
who
helped me through the byzantine process
of trying to find
records you go from one finding aid to
another it's a whole room
as large as this one of nothing but
finding aids and so it's one
one binder after another that leads you
to another
you're tracking usually the contract
number that the scientist had with the
federal government
and so during world war ii linus pauling
had had a contract number through
caltech and so i was trying to try to
track that down i had an archivist
working with me took three days i had my
i got my my call slipped together i knew
my call numbers i put it in and the you
know put into the desk and an hour later
i had my box
the box box was labeled p
for people with the last name
beginning with p so i opened it up and
there was nothing in there about pauling
and
i had been there so long
and i had never done any archival
research so it's kind of cool to me i
had this box of records from world war
ii
so i just started flipping through them
and
i came across a memo that was written to
the
the lead public health official in the
state of massachusetts
it was from a federal researcher the
letterhead was the national research
council and
the letter asked if federal researchers
could come in and infect patients at the
boston psychopathic hospital with
malaria so that drugs could be used
against the infections
no less than the war's outcome was at
stake that the
the war department was experiencing
horrendous casualties because of malaria
and the the war department needed a drug
and the scientific community was
pitching in to help and
would he also allow massachusetts state
hospital patients to become a part of
this and he said yes so boston the
boston psychopathic hospital was one of
about a half dozen
who allowed in these researchers to
infect their patients with malaria for
these drug tests this is the malaria
project this is the malaria project how
long did it go on how many people were
infected what were the results
so it started um
you know it's
it really started in 1940 before the war
before the united states entered the war
because scientists anticipated that
malaria would be the biggest problem of
the war department
this was before normandy this is before
the battles in europe this is when we
were envisioning
getting to
hitler
through his underbelly through north
africa i mean this was it took a while
for strategists to get there but we
figured italy would be a part of it we
knew that to contain japan we needed we
would be in the south pacific where
malaria was everywhere
um so a few
a very clever scientist named lowell
kagashel proposed this project he said
look the germans
have come up with a project a process
for trying to find a drug for malaria
and we should we should model that here
they uh they use
their drug companies to come up with
compounds and then
the the the federal researchers infect
patients with malaria and then test
those drugs on them and we should do
that here
but the
the actual project itself didn't start
until the war department really saw that
they had a problem and that was when the
fall of bataan was largely because of
malaria and we were in guadalcanal and
on the verge of losing
that island which was very important
strategic island because of malaria and
the war department opened the spigot he
they the um
uh uh
the the the
um leaders of the of the departments
that were overseeing the health of these
soldiers
started attending these meetings where
all the malariologists were and said
we're we need you and we need you to
expand this program tenfold we need 400
scientists working on this we need the
drug all the drug companies that we can
get involved in this and so
and so you saw this this small project
turn into
the largest medical effort
of the war it was the number one medical
priority of the war to find a
cure for malaria
mental health patients
right so
there to understand why this was
acceptable
you need to understand the history of
malaria and syphilis
these are two diseases
that
that
worked
against one another so
a
austrian
scientist named
named julius yarag he
was a psychiatrist and
had
surmised that
when
his patients his mental health patients
came down with severe fever
um that sometimes
they would be um be
better off afterwards that their their
mental health problems would disappear
and so he surmised there was something
to do with a fever that could treat
their mental health issues and so he
started infecting
his patients with all kinds of microbes
including tuberculosis he had a german
friend give him a little vial of
tuberculosis and he tried he gave it to
his patients to see if if he could get
the fevers high enough to cure them of
their of their mental mental illness and
these experiments kind of spiraled out
of control
but he
he's
thought that malaria might be a good
candidate for treating these patients
because certain types of malaria you can
control with quinine not the kind that
you got in africa but the kind that you
picked up in europe the kind the kind of
malaria the kind that you the malaria
that you picked up in in europe and that
was called vivax
this this is vivex is still all over
asia it's in south america now but it
used to be also be all over europe so if
you used vivax malaria to induce a fever
and allow the fevers to go up high
enough
and then treat the fevers with quinine
30 of the time you could cure
the patient of what's called
neurosyphilis it's a
syphilis spirochete that would
infect brain cells and cause brain
damage
these fevers would could kill the
syphilis in in these patients and they
would walk away 100 cured
so this became a standard treatment he
he won a nobel prize in 1927 for it this
became a standard treatment for
late-stage syphilis neurosyphilis
and
malariologists
who were still in their infancy because
it had only been you know a couple of
decades since we figured out that
malaria was caused
by these parasites carried by mosquitoes
saw this as an opportunity to study the
parasites
because you couldn't grow them
in a petri dish you couldn't culture
them you couldn't pass them around in
vials like you could with tuberculosis
and share share these microbes with
other scientists so you could study them
you had to have an infected person
so
the
state hospitals that ran what was called
malaria therapy
had
ample numbers of people infected with
malaria so it was very innocent
first stage for malariologists to come
in and study malaria they would just go
into the state hospitals that were
running
the the therapy for these patients and
draw their blood and study the parasites
and
it didn't take long for
the
uh the dynamic to flip so that the
malaria community was paying for the
the treatment of syphilis patients in
state hospitals so that they could use
these patients to study them and also to
test drugs on them and when the war
broke this was the state that these two
fields these two medical fields were
it's the psychiatric field of psychiatry
and julius jarg warning these
malariologists not to overstep their
bounds to use only vivax which is can be
controlled by quinine not the one in
africa is called falciparum and that it
quinine is not a reliable treatment of
it
and
he warned them not to use mosquitoes
for the infections because
they're when you when you invite an
infection by way of a mosquito you're
inviting
every stage of that parasite into the
body not just the blood stage which if
you took if i took blood from you and
you had malaria
and injected it into another patient
that patient would just have that blood
stage
of malaria
and if you isolated that person and
didn't let mosquitoes bite that person
it would never spread it would never it
would never go it wouldn't it's not it's
beyond the liver stage so it's not going
to stay in your body and you're not
going to walk away and have another
outbreak in of of parasites and then
pass it on
the field of malaria
did not find these
these restrictions convenient and so
to study malaria you needed to have the
mosquitoes you needed to use more than
just vivax
parasites you needed to use all of the
parasites that caused the different
types of malaria
and when the when the war broke
the germany and the united states
developed these projects
that used all phases of the parasites
and all types of parasites to try to
understand how to treat how to come up
with the treatment karen masterson when
you discovered that memo in that box
accidentally did you
have any concept that it would grow into
the malaria project
you know i didn't because i was a daily
reporter
and i didn't
i i thought i was writing an
article that i would pitch to a magazine
i wondered if i had found another
tuskegee syphilis experiment
where where um
men black men in in tuskegee uh were um
not treated for their syphilis because
they weren't told that they had it and
so that researchers could
simply observe the life cycle of this of
this disease
which was horrendous because there was a
treatment for syphilis at the time um i
thought i had something like that but i
i spent enough time with
uh with researchers and i even went i
won a fellowship to go down to cdc and
spend some time um with researchers
there and especially with one one man
bill collins who had been at it long
enough to have actually done some of
that research on state hospital patients
because even after the war state
hospital patients with
late stage syphilis were still given
malaria as a treatment so that
malariologists could study the parasites
and he was one of those people and he he
made me understand that
this was a very nuanced project that
there was
there were there were
many
considerations
that one needed to understand to put
what went on during world war ii in
context
and once i spent time with him i
realized there was no way that i could
write this
in in a magazine length piece that it
had to be a book and i had
book writing friends who kept telling me
you have a book you need to write this
book and i kept saying well you know i'm
not sure about this give me some time so
i um i just i continued my treks up to
the national archives i went through 500
boxes
and found bits and pieces of the story
in you know a variety of different
record groups and
and once once i saw the
saw the story once i had the narrative
arc in my mind
i understood that i had a book and so
i
found an agent and we got
a publisher and i wrote it yeah
is this written so that
the layman can understand
it is written for the layman it is a
narrative i am a storyteller so i know
that uh that that
people like to read about
other people and so i chose
three scientists really to focus on
my main scientists is lowell cogishelle
who i talk about who i talked about
earlier he um he's a very interesting he
was a very interesting man he was a very
good man he was a um
he grew up a poor
poor farm boy who didn't want to farm
and so to get out of farming he
studied biology he went to
indiana university and studied biology
and
told and he you know he he said
repeatedly totally by accident he
tripped into malaria which i could
identify with because it was totally by
accident for me too but he ended up
getting a
fellowship to
go down and study the swamps
in leesburg georgia
as a limnologist a liminologist is
somebody who studies freshwater is a the
limnologist for a rockefeller foundation
project
the only malaria station
in the united states and it was run by
samuel darling who was one of the
leading thinkers on malaria and what
they were doing down there in in in
south georgia in 1924
was trying to figure out what mosquitoes
carried malaria because the malaria
burden in the south was so horrendous
that no one felt that there would be any
kind of economic growth in these
southern states with malaria because of
this disease
so
a low cognition went down and he went
into the swamps and he had to kill a
couple of snakes that came at him but he
he studied the larva
the mosquito larva to see if certain
chemicals would kill them
and that was his introduction
to malaria and he became because of
going down there as a college student he
became one of the country's
few malaria experts and so the
rockefeller foundation and the u.s
public health service called on him
every summer in between his studies
because he's he he decided that
from biology he was going to go to
medical school so he had many years in
in university and every summer he would
go and he would work on malaria in the
south and through that became a an
expert and was
one of the leading thinkers and most
innovative thinkers on malaria
when the world went to war
what's your job here at johns hopkins i
teach i teach so i teach writing courses
but i teach writing courses for science
students and i have one course that is
specifically geared geared toward public
health students
so i i ask them uh we it's a the one for
the public health students is a workshop
and um i send them out into the city of
baltimore
where they have to find stories
and they have to
actually get on the ground and
work with communities a lot of them will
look at hiv a lot of them will look like
look at
heroin addiction because baltimore is
the heroin capital of the of the country
they come up with they come up with a
public health topic that they that they
want to explore and then they have to
get on the ground and they have to find
a story and then they bring it back to
the class and we workshop it and i help
them i help them develop their ideas
into a story with an arc so that they
can when in the future if they want to
if they want to tell stories about their
research and the work that they do
they'll have the skills to do it
have you had malaria
no i have not
i have not had malaria i i when i was
sitting next to bill collins down at cdc
when i was on the fellowship
we would
chop the heads off of mosquitoes that
have been infected so the mosquitoes
would
would
pick up malaria from the monkey house
so they were cycling the lives of these
parasites and they'd bring mosquitoes to
the monkey house where the where the the
racist monkeys were infected with
malaria and then they'd bring them back
to bill collins
lab put them in incubators for that week
to 10 days sometimes two weeks for the
the parasites to
uh you know to diffuse develop the egg
sac and for the egg the egg sac to burst
with these parasites and then we would
catch them just after the parasites were
in the saliva we put them under a
magnifying machine chop off their heads
and then i would hand the head to bill
and he would look under a microscope for
the parasites
and while we were doing that one day
an infected mosquito flew off and
and i was like phil um we have a problem
here there's uh an infected mosquito in
the room
and he looked up and he was such such a
colorful interesting funny man and you
know cervic in his own way and he looked
up and he goes
gosh i hate to see that and then he went
back down on his microscope
and
i i didn't understand this community
malaria and i didn't understand the
parasites well enough yet because i
hadn't really launched into the
different species and really tried to
understand what they all what they the
the the big differences differences
between them
and so i just tracked it because i
didn't want malaria and i i tracked his
flight pattern and i lunged forward and
i just slapped the life out of it i
killed it and
i could see bill's kind of mouth curl up
and i went home and i told my husband
i was in a room with an infectious
mosquito i could have you know i could
have contracted malaria but it was not
until about five years later or four
years later when i really started
studying the monkey malarias because
monkey malarias were important to the
project
that i realized the kind of monkey
malaria that we were working with with
could not jump species so he was just
kind of having fun with me because i
didn't understand that this plasmodium
in ui
was not going to infect me that there
was a mosquito loose in the lab was not
a big deal but i didn't know it at the
time so no i've never had malaria
i
traveled with a friend who came down
with malaria when i was in africa and
she had falciparum and
we were told when we got into the clinic
that we that uh we got her there just in
time um because her uh
she was showing the early signs of
cerebral malaria which which can kill
you and the drug that was used to treat
her chloroquine which was the one
product that came out of this malaria
project it was the wonder drug that the
project found which we actually ended up
stealing from the germans
but still in use today
and it's still in use today
yeah in fact most of the drugs in use
today
were created during this project so when
a drug becomes
ineffectual because of resistance
scientists at walter reed will go back
to the drawing board we'll go back to
this series of fourteen 000 compounds
that were made during the war
and we'll pull another one off the shelf
and study it
there there were maybe a dozen that
still that showed promise but then when
the war ended there was no more research
money to develop them so walter reed
scientists have gone back
taken them off the shelf developed them
made them into different analogs
and then handed them off to
pharmaceutical companies to develop and
use again in these programs overseas
until those drugs would become
ineffectual because of resistance and
then would start all over again and just
about every drug used today except for
the art of medicines that's a chinese
herb that we learned about from the
chinese that's the that's the one drug
that didn't come from this project
and finally karen masterson how has your
friend's life changed since she got
malaria
are there limitations on what she can do
no she's fully recovered the interesting
thing about it she stays with her
in her liver this is the african
malaria this is falciparum and
falciparum does not have a liver stage
which is why
it's
it it is um it is not a
type of malaria that can survive well
in northern climates it doesn't have to
will not hide in the liver and then come
out when the mosquitoes come out this is
that that that malaria is called vivax
and that you find in asia and you find
in south america and there's tiny tiny
bits of vivax in africa but there's
another whole reason why you don't see
much of it there it has to do with
a blood mutation that makes most
africans completely immune to it but
falciparum you have a you have an
intense infection
but when it clears it's gone and it
doesn't come back
little bit from karen masterson the u.s
government's secret mission to find a
miracle cure the malaria project is the
name of the book
book tv is on location at johns hopkins
university
book tv is on twitter and facebook and
we want to hear from you tweet us
twitter